well there's so many moving parts we've
got new teammates and Lonzo ball Brandon
Ingram Josh mark
Zion is a rookie coming in as Braz Dacus
get to the end want rj Barrett get a
hand a little bit here to start this
game up Barrett on the LOB and he's back
total on zoetry as you see the back
screen by Mitchell Robertson they clear
the back side Kevin Aqsa was passed over
a couple of times
last year for the Rising Stars Challenge
game about the left hand by press take
it and he carries himself that way too
there's himself like a throw grass snake
is with it did not attend college Braz
Dacus did is he went to Michigan and hit
Andre to sit some nights and watch and
learn I'll rather than have to be in the
fire all the time you have to be about
winning you have to make sure that
everything to do not just the distance
it's a small window to make it knocks on
the drive and one knocking at the glass
as Dacus off the Robinson screen
actually rejects it and a good
boy he is dynamic as Dacus and tough
shot time to spin me you're gonna cut
him off to his strong hand he goes and
gets right back to the left side as a
result of that earthquake that was
centered about a hundred and fifty miles
west of here
they were upset nice strong Chinese kids
got game this with both hands you're
gonna end up but the cut often times
with defenders take it away you're
strong long with Knox Mitchell Robinson
a little pick and roll game here Braz
Dacus all the way to the bucket and a
nice finish all time our second all-time
leading shot blocker as Dacus Knicks
very much alive it'll need a three but
he will take one anyway
roll so he gets mr. Robinson to change
the angle a little bit on the screen
Braz Dacus he will fire and hit biggie
presidents the work he out of Michigan
it may sound hyperbolic but it's not he
is as pres Dacus gets into the block
party Mitchell Robinson is already one
of the best shot blockers in the NBA
mm-hmm yes
I mean you know no hesitation for him
couldn't get his feet gathered together
a little bit too close on that jump shot
the Raptors out scoring the next twenty
four to nine in the second quarter but
for as Dacus with the steal there's
Perez Dacus driving lobbing it to
Mitchell Robinson nice set up by Braz
Dacus or Deloitte created that loose
ball nice hustle by Kadeem Allen chased
down by Barrett and here's pres de cos
good hustle by the Knicks
it was 15-point Raptors lead nice pass
and Hernandez was blocked by Brad Dacus
Matthew prophecy we have seven he only
has eight points in the game what a shot
that one it was there's Brad Dacus yes a
slithery move to the cup so there was a
friend of mine Steve green didn't drink
he's like I know what to do go - that's
not in the coach's manual on grapevine
he was in the second round by the Knicks
a season ago he was second team
all-rookie all-nba and brass dicus might
be on the same track the way he's
playing right now after that bucket
living out his basketball dream it
doesn't always have to be in the NBA
razz Dacus likes that spin move
and he timed out Robinson you like him
the fairy buff you take this game
translates to yes I do
do you know yo kids was that good no I
didn't think that he too was a
second-round pick
like Braz Dacus a second-round pick you
spent some time down at Disney looking
at Mickey Mouse
I love Jamar and I you know if I had to
take a early pick for MVP Rookie of the
Year that allowed Knox to get the dump
or the player to score the basket
Matthews mrs. Robinson on the other end
Mitchell Robinson with the finish and
the Nixon back in front we play on and
there was virtually no interruption
there Mitchell Robinson throws Dacus
with the fee with the hoop for the
Wizards Bruce brown of the Pistons had a
triple-double and some early play
earlier this week that's not gonna make
you a better teammate that's going to
make you only
plain steel buy a banana
to Perez dinkus trying to get their
second win here at summer league knots
pitches it out pres Davis for three
[Applause]
cutbush learn spreads his arms let's
space the floor
let's take us for three big believe the
14 what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content